okay so what I'm talking about today is
a molecule called caravan and caravan is
an organic molecule which comes in a
couple of different forms and these
different forms are called stereoisomers
so what stereo isomers are it's two
different forms of the exact same
molecule but the difference is the
molecules are just arranged slightly
differently carbon comes in these two
forms this form of carbon has a minus
sign in front of it and this one has a
plus sign in front of it
they look the same they're both yellow
liquids but there's a crucial difference
between the two both of these types of
carbone smell differently one of them
smells like caraway and the other smells
like spearmint you'll have to take my
word for that but they definitely do
this one definitely those smell
experiment and this is what contributes
to the smell of spearmint this form of
the molecule is in mint and obviously
this one gives you the smell of caraway
seeds but the reason that are different
and this is the important bit these two
forms are actually mirror images of each
other so you can think of this like your
hands your hands you have a right hand
on the left hand your hands are mirror
images of each other
you cannot overlay your right hand on
your left hand you always have your
thumb sticking out here in the wrong
place and it's exactly the same with
this molecule you can switch this
molecule around so it looks the same
down here but because of this hydrogen
here it's not the same that's what makes
the difference so these are mirror
images of each other these two molecules
these two forms of this molecule and are
called enantiomers so on YouTube
obviously I can't show you the smell of
these two different forms of caravan but
I can show you something over here
because enantiomers these enantiomers
will do something actually very
interesting with light and what I have
here is a polarizing filter if I put my
two different enantiomers onto it if you
look here as I rotate this filter over
the sample of caravel you can see that a
particular angles one of the samples
will let the light through whereas the
other one won't it looks black and then
at different angles the other sample
lets the light through
there's an enormous number of what we
call chiral molecules in nature and
examples are amino acids in proteins
they are all chiral molecules DNA is
another example where you usually have a
right-handed spiral rather than a
left-handed spiral so nature is
particularly fond of particular forms of
these chiral molecules